[Music]
December is upon us the final chance for
Publishers to influence the games we
play holiday season 2022. like usual I
found a bunch of games to play for free
and one which costs less than a dollar
we'll get to that soon so for the last
time in 2022 here's the best games
releasing this month
we shall begin with Marvel's midnight
Suns the quickest way to describe this
is Marvel crossed with x-com yup it's a
tactics game we are a member of a
superhero super group which are sent
into daily battles we then take turns
performing moves and moving around the
battlefield kind of like chess in the
x-com games weapon accuracy always meant
there was a chance you would miss your
attack whereas superheroes simply don't
miss so instead a new card system is
here to randomly restrict or change each
fight that's only half the game the
other half of the game seems to be a
social simulator we all live at The
Abbey when outside of combat kinda like
a frat house for superheroes and it's
your job to build up relationships with
other members of the team do it well
enough and Wolverine Iron Man blade
whoever you successfully spend time with
will have access to upgraded skills and
abilities as your relationship grows say
the wrong thing and then suddenly doctor
strange doesn't like you well Pete
doesn't like anyone to be midnight Suns
takes the Marvel superhero formula and
does something quite unique with it so
I'm looking forward to it Marvel
midnight Sun's release is on December
2nd on every current platform including
the switch
[Music]
okay the real headliner for the month of
December is the Callisto protocol a
survival horror outing in space let's
address the elephant in the room if
you're getting dead space Vibes it's for
good reason the settings are almost
identical and the game's director
formally created the entire Dead Space
series and it just so happens a new Dead
Space game is coming in January to
further confuse this situation we play
as an Interstellar Freight transporter
in the year 2320 and then of course
things go wrong and we must survive an
alien invasion which mutates the
inhabitants of a prison we must go
through using anything we can get our
hands on to survive such as the grip gun
a gravity gun that lets us pick up
objects and enemies and use them as a
shield or just yank them across the room
with their limbs flying off lovely of
course that's only one way to approach
encounters we've also seen devastating
melee attacks subtle Stealth gameplay
and we are told it's all linked to skill
trees for progression the Callisto
protocol is heavily emphasizing the
importance of story and to back that up
a few big name actors from film and TV
are on board with the project the battle
with dead space Starts Now the Callisto
protocol releases on December 2nd on the
PlayStations the Xboxes and the PC
December will also see The Return of the
Need for Speed series Unbound changes
the tone and feel of the franchise and
it kinda looks anime at its core it's
more Need for Speed you've played for
years racing by day and night in which
cops are itching to take you down
Unbound has confirmed over 140 cars
including many licenses from Aston
Martin Ford McLaren and Porsche to name
a few customization is a huge part of
the game with access to tuning and body
kits for all vehicles creating thousands
of potential setups and combinations for
those people who really want to be fully
in control of their ride the story kicks
off with two friends running an auto
shop and after a burglary they must take
part in illegal races to win back their
stolen gear and of course they get
hooked on that adrenaline and keep going
multiplayer modes have been confirmed in
the open world city and hey if you're
getting flashbacks to the cop AI in
older games you should know that police
AI is now adjustable the Kamikaze cops
are definitely an issue of the past Need
for Speed Unbound is the third game in a
row dropping on December 2nd but this
time only the PS5 Xbox series and PC are
confirmed last gen consoles Abby left
behind
back in 2007 a portable Final Fantasy
game called Crisis Core released on the
PSP a much-loved game on a relatively
small platform which branched out the
Final Fantasy VII story now in 2022 the
game has been remastered adapted and
evolved into Crisis Core Final Fantasy
VII reunion that's a lot of words acting
as a prequel to Final Fantasy VII in
fact seven years prior to that story
revolving all around Zack a pivotal
character in The overarching Narrative
who has a past shrouded in mystery and
now it's time to see it from his point
of view for fans of Final Fantasy 7
remake reunion is a must play game
reunion releases on December 13th on
Playstation Xbox PC and twitch at 50 50
pounds or 60 Euros so a little less than
a full price game
[Music]
A reduced price game you may want to
know about is hello neighbor 2. the
original game was a clever take on
breaking into a neighbor's home to find
out their Eerie Secrets the idea was
good the implementation was not so good
well finally after many iterations and
improvements it's time for hello
neighbor too this time we play as a
journalist who comes to town in the
pursuit of a story The call gameplay is
then stealth horror we must break into
houses around the neighborhood as their
owners pursuers here's the best bit
those people will adapt to your actions
for instance if you constantly come in
at night time they'll sleep during the
day so they'll be alert the moment you
venture onto their property when chased
they'll look in more realistic places
and if you hide in the same place more
than once it's likely they will figure
that out as you adapt they adapt keeping
the gameplay Dynamic and that feeling of
uncertainty and anxiety constantly with
you if you want to break and Enter look
out for hello neighbor 2 on December 6th
on Playstation Xbox and PC
[Music]
okay let's do some free stuff and it's a
really weird month for free games first
a few games that released after last
month video Destroy All Humans clone
Carnage is totally free on Steam it's
totally free on Xbox but for some reason
on Playstation it costs 2 cents in the
US 25 cent in Europe and here in the UK
it costs 20 pence I have no idea why a
standalone multiplayer mode supporting
four players online or two in local
co-op split screen with six maps and
four game modes to play it's basically
some dumb Alien Invasion fun with
friends for a few evenings it won't last
you forever but it's a good change of
pace and it also has the platinum trophy
that's your jam next Gundam Evolution
official releases on November the 30th
or December the 1st depending on where
you live in the world it's a six on six
Arena shooter focusing solely on Gundam
mobile suits and their fighting prowess
the devs have worked on a Boost system
to accelerate your Gundam towards fight
or to evade attacks and that leads into
a class system where different Gundams
have slightly different properties it's
quite usual if your suit has more Health
you are expected to play as a tank and
protect your teammates and gain aggro
the supports have healing abilities and
everyone else is there to fire as many
bullets as possible to achieve the
objective with overwatch's recent
Revival and going free to play Gundam
Evolution will need all the players it
can so if this is appealing to you you
hold the power to keep it alive on
Playstation Xbox and PC
oh I did intend to tell you about a
Japanese MMORPG which made its way over
to console last month internal Kingdom
battle Peak it's known as a PC and
mobile game which is trying to add more
platforms from for its player base with
cross play and cross progression Eternal
Kingdom follows the usual High fantasy
MMO tropes by creating a character with
a certain playstyle and taking on
missions in this vastly open world I'd
love to tell you about how great the
gameplay is but here in the UK the game
was removed from the PlayStation Store
I've reached out to find out why yet
nothing has returned to me it's been
suggested December will see it returned
from what I'm told though the na version
is up and running quite smoothly so it's
an option if you're looking for a new
MMO on mobile PC and console right now
[Music]
oh did you hear the news about the
Witcher 3 check your game's collection
dust it off because if you own that game
from many years ago you'll be granted a
free upgrade to the next gen version on
PS5 and Xbox series on December 14th The
Witcher 3 world Hunt is one of the
highest rated RPGs ever made and now
it's back the update adds improved
Graphics Lighting and Sound mods and
also new DLC tied to the Netflix TV show
if you don't know we play as geralt a
Witcher who takes on many missions to
slay beasts in the open world whilst the
constant pressure of the hunt chasing
down Siri is upon them Siri is
effectively garop's adopted daughter the
original game took around 50 hours to
finish and it was amazing oh and uh Pro
tip if you don't own the physical game
but don't want to pay full price for the
new version then look around your local
second-hand game store to find it for a
few dollars pounds of euros and then the
questions will begin is The Witcher 3
the greatest RPG of all time so that's
December what you playing I'm definitely
going back to The Witcher what about you
I'm Adam you're awesome I'll see you
next time
[Music]